[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily the
sarah lawrence college sex cult where do
you think you are
you think you can just do this to people
and just get away with hurting everybody
like this
the final prosecution witness testifies
as the government rested case in the
federal trial plus will a man accused of
murdering his wife kids and family dog
be allowed to use the insanity defense
any
evidence about the defendant's mental
health status
diminished capacity or
any evidence of baker acts would be
irrelevant and would mislead the jury in
this particular case and the parkland
high school shooting could jurors be
shown the remains of marjory stoneman
douglas high school but first the
olympian attempted murder trial they had
about
one second to
make a decision
and the decision was he was running up i
was in the house and i pretty much had
to leap and punch him law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckman strong
testimony continues in new jersey as
part of the olympian attempted murder
trial following the two-day testimony of
shooting victim lauren canorack robert
goodwin takes the stand detailing what
led up to the shooting
back in 2019 goodwin and cataract were
dating and lived together on the
property of michael barisson barrisone
is charged with two counts of attempted
murder for shooting counteract twice in
the chest and later firing a shot at
goodwin defense attorneys say barisone
feared for his life at the time of the
shooting and suffered from mental health
issues even sleeping in a stable leading
up to the incident ahead of the shooting
barristone a one-time olympian was
training cataract in dressage riding as
she lived on his property in the days
leading up to the shooting a string of
911 calls were made by both parties
barrisone saying he tried to evict
canarac and kanarak saying she was being
harassed on the stand goodwin told
jurors how he reacted after kanarak was
shot in the chest
so after
michael shot lauren twice
what did you and you said you were
watching him what did you see him do
next
well she turned and ran
and he ran it looked like he was chasing
after her but then he pointed the gun at
me and fire a shot at me
you didn't get shot
did you no
after you saw or heard the glass
shattering around the window what did
you do next
uh
i think at that point i realized what
was going on um
i realized warm is outside michael was
outside with a gun
shooting at us so
you know i got up and
went to go charge outside
when you said that you uh punched him do
you remember which hand you punched him
with punched him with my right hand
what happened after you punched him
uh
i think i danced him a little bit
he kind of stood there a little bit
my hand was in complete agony and pain
um
i think i
think i might have swung at him
again michael
you know
then
turned around and i didn't know if he
was going to chase after lauren but as
soon as he gave me his back i took
advantage of it and what did you do
threw him in a chokehold
and what happened when you put him in
the chokehold
uh he passed out
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney karen nance and co-host terry
austin karen barisson fired at two
people one of which seemed to terrorize
him and another that attacked him do you
think the defense could compare barizone
to kyle renthouse and would that be
convincing
i think that that's an option that the
defense has they don't have a strong
case to begin with because we we don't
it's not a whodunit we know it was bare
stone they shot the that at least he
shot lauren and he attempted to shoot
robert as well so the question is were
the facts surrounding this particular
incident enough to get him to in his
mind uh one consider uh self-defense and
to the insanity and with kyle
rittenhouse we look at the circumstances
surrounding the black lives matter
movement and that particular event that
was happening there in wisconsin so i
think that there could be a comparison
in terms of looking at the state of mind
of the individual that that we have
before us and we have the 9-1-1 calls
that that mr barrison made prior to this
incident to the police indicating that
he had some concerns a lot of concerns
about them being on his property and he
also testified he didn't testify but
there was evidence that he was suffering
from some type of depression so i think
that there is a viable option to do that
in this absolutely now terry what is
your impression of robert goodwin as a
witness how do you think the jury is
reacting to his testimony
well he was definitely better on direct
but i think as far as the
cross-examination he was extremely
evasive and he was arrogant he was
leaning back it was like pulling teeth
and every single time defense counsel
had to continuously refresh his
recollection he could not get goodwin to
admit to even the simplest things that
were actually in text between him and
lauren he also claimed he didn't know
how to shoot a gun and in fact he was a
marine so not credible as far as i'm
concerned he's not doing well in front
of the jury yeah a couple holes in that
testimony we'll see how that continues
as the case of new jersey versus michael
barissone progresses switching gears now
to celebrity news where the producer for
the academy awards breaks his silence
just days after will smith slap comedian
chris rock on the oscars stage the slap
aired live last sunday night during the
94th annual academy awards as rock went
to present an award he made a joke about
the 1997 movie gij in which actress demi
moore sports a shaved head he joked that
actress jada pinkett smith the wife of
will smith would appear in the movie
sequel after that smith walked onto the
stage and slapped chris rock though
producers cut the audio of the live
broadcast reporters in the room noted
smith yelled at rock to quote keep my
wife's name out your
mouth all this comes after jaded pinkett
smith revealed to fans that she suffers
from alopecia and now struggles to grow
hair on her head academy awards producer
will packer tells good morning america
smith was asked to leave the awards but
refused later los angeles police was on
call to arrest the soon-to-be oscar
winner will smith
the lapd
came and needed to talk to chris
and so they came into my office
and
they were
laying out very clearly
what chris's rights were
and
they were saying this is battery we will
go get him we are prepared we're
prepared to get him right now you can
press charges we can arrest him as they
were talking chris was um
he was being very dismissive of
those options he was like no i'm fine he
was like no no no
in more news out of california parole is
once again denied for a famed murder
member of the charles manson cult this
week
california's governor blocked parole for
72 year old leslie van houten who
infamously took part in the te la in the
tail of bianca murders in 1969 when she
was just 19 years old at the time van
halen was a follower of charles manson
who worked to start a race war in los
angeles by orchestrating a string of
highly publicized murders since her
conviction van gaan has had 21 parole
hearings five of which recommended her
release this year a parole board again
recommended her release but governor
gavin newsom blocked the release saying
van halen quote currently possesses an
unreasonable danger to society if
released from prison at this time
still ahead on law and crime daily years
after the deaths of his wife children
and family dog a former physical
therapist is set to stand trial for
their murders but first parkland school
shooter nicholas cruz will soon be
sentenced for the crime we look ahead to
the coming jury selection
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back prosecutors say jury
members should be allowed inside the
parkland school shooting crime scene as
part of shooter nicholas cruz's
sentencing phase this just days before
jury selection is expected to begin in
october of last year defendant nicholas
cruz pled guilty in the marjory stoneman
douglas high school shooting in february
2018 17 people were killed and 17 more
injured when crews opened fire in the
high school the building was sealed off
after the shooting leaving behind
visible blood stains and bullet holes
prosecutors argued jurors should walk
through the school to get a better
understanding of the shooting spree the
defense attorneys argue the jurors will
already see gruesome video and hear
disturbing testimony about the attack in
all 20 jurors will likely be seated jury
selection is expected to begin on monday
and last for several weeks law on crime
daily is set to bring you live coverage
when the penalty phase begins
back to break down the long-anticipated
parkland shooter jury selection is
criminal defense attorney karen names
and terry austin
terry
we saw this in the brett hankinson trial
do you think the jurors should be
allowed to physically go to the scene of
the shooting
actually brian i don't think they should
be allowed to go there if i were the
judge i would say no and the reason is
if they go to the scene this is a
horrific crime and going to that scene
seeing what happened where the kids were
shot absolutely is going to affect that
jury and what the judge has to determine
is it more probative or is it more
prejudicial and if it's prejudicial then
they should not go to the scene and
while obviously this was a horrible
crime and nicholas cruz absolutely
should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law i think going to the
scene is going to be extremely
prejudicial now karen let's talk jury
selection if you were the defense what
kind of questions would you want to ask
prospective jurors
well the most important thing is what is
their position on the death penalty
because that's those are the two options
life without the possibility of parole
or the death penalty so you want to make
sure that the
the jury one is going to be fair that
that's going to sit so in addition to
wanting to know if what their position
is on the death penalty because they're
going to be excluded for cause meaning
that they're that the decision here is
should he be put to death or not and so
that once we get over that hurdle the
issue is from the defense perspective
will they be willing to listen to all
the evidence that's going to be
presented on both sides before making a
determination and making sure that they
haven't formed their position ahead of
time yeah but interesting to see how
this election process
unravels it's going to be a very long
and i think a hard process for both
sides thank you both also in the
sunshine state a florida highway patrol
report says a 13 year old boy was
driving recklessly when he crashed his
dirt bike last december while trying to
speed away from patrol officers it
happened just one day after christmas as
boynton beach police attempted to pull
over stanley davis iii according to the
report davis was going 85 miles an hour
when officer mark sohn tried to pull him
over the officer had a history of being
involved in deadly vehicle pursuits and
was suspended at one time from violating
rules and policies during a pursuit
officials now say he will not face
charges in davis death from here there
will be an internal affairs
investigation to determine if police
department policies were violated
well-known civil rights attorney
benjamin crump is representing the boy's
family he claimed sohn struck and killed
davis and violated policies during the
attempted traffic stop a wrongful death
lawsuit was filed on behalf of the davis
family in january
coming up on law and crime daily the
prosecution wraps up its case in the
sarah lawrence college cult federal
trial plus a quadruple homicide in the
shadow of disney world we look ahead to
the trial of family man and accused
murderer anthony tony
[Music]
welcome back a florida judge rules
mental health issues will not be allowed
in the coming case of anthony tote who's
accused of killing his wife three
children and their family dog not far
from disney world federal authorities
found toad's wife two sons daughter and
the family dog dead at their celebration
florida home in early 2020. they were
originally there to arrest the physical
therapist on unrelated insurance fraud
charges in a jailhouse letter to his
father tote claimed his wife was to
blame for the killings when tote was
arrested he said he had taken benadryl
in an attempt to commit suicide the
judge previously ruled to allow one
confession from tote but exclude another
after detectives failed to fully inform
him of his miranda rights his defense
team argued the medication may have had
an impact on his capacity to understand
what he was saying at a hearing this
week the assistant state attorney argued
evidence about his diminished capacity
or mental health would mislead the jury
toe's defense said they plan to bring up
the issue of his mental stability after
the deaths the judge then made his
ruling
i am unaware of any case law that
supports the defense's contention that
an argument of diminished capacity
or suicidal ideations
in any way affects the determination of
a trier affects
determination as to whether statements
are credible or not credible or what
wait to give to those statements the
court finds it
to be
clear
that
the issue of diminished capacity is as
inadmissible in the state of florida in
the guilt phase and the court is going
to grant the
state's motion there is case law that
supports that any medications that mr
tote was on at the time of his
confessions
should be considered if they are
established by competent evidence
jurisdiction for toad's trial is set to
begin monday law and crime will bring
you capital gamble coverage as the case
unfolds
criminal defense attorney karen nance
and co-host terry austin join us again
as we break down florida versus anthony
toad terry the judge's decision to
exclude toad's mental health we just
heard it there but do you agree and does
that all but destroy the defense's case
well actually it eviscerates the
defense's case what else is he going to
be able to claim there's no question
that he committed the crime this is not
a whodunit and in fact there's a
confession although part of the
confession was excluded some of it has
been included and the part that is
included definitely talks about killing
his wife and children this type of
defense the mental the capacity is
definitely going to help his case and if
it's out his case is basically nothing
he's got that confession
and
there's no question that anyone else did
it so i think it's going to really hurt
his case all right karen terry said it's
basically nothing but i still got to ask
the question so only one of two
confessions come in no mention of mental
health issues what do you think opening
statements will focus on then
well
we don't have too much to go on all at
all as from the defense perspective the
only thing is to go back to what his
original statement was which is not
really credible which is his wife killed
the the children and the dog committed
um suicide herself and and tried to drug
him with the with the benadryl i don't
think it's a very viable argument at all
but that's all he has to go with that i
can see if we can't
the defense can't bring in the insanity
or diminish capacity defense all right
it's going to be interesting to see what
the defense comes up with of course we
know what the prosecution is saying in
this case but as we said the loan crime
network will have you covered for
capital galvan coverage as the case
comes up when we come back will the
sarah lawrence college cult federal
trial soon be handed over to a jury the
prosecution arrests its case but what's
next for the defense that's ahead on law
and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily the
government rests his case in the new
york trial of accused sarah lawrence sex
cult leader lawrence ray this after the
final prosecution witness was called to
the stand the mother of three of rey's
alleged victims rey is facing several
federal charges including tax evasion
racketeering sex trafficking and money
laundering among others he's accused of
running a sex cult over the last decade
which he allegedly started out of his
daughter's on-campus housing at sarah
lawrence college in 2010. jurors have
heard from several of rey's alleged
victims including claudio jury who
testified about becoming a sex worker at
ray's suggestion and rey is accused of
taking the millions of dollars she
earned the jury also heard from three
other alleged victims who are all
siblings santos felicia and yolitsa
rosario on friday their mother took the
stand as the government's final witness
trial exhibits give a glimpse of the
strained cause between the siblings and
their mother law and crimes adam
classfeld is following this case from
inside the courtroom and was there on
friday for mauricio rosario's testimony
the government wrapped up its case and
one of the last witnesses to take the
stand was maurice rosario she is the
mother of three of the alleged victims
in this case felicia rosario those who
have been watching this unfold from the
beginning may remember was larry ray's
ex-girlfriend and the woman whom he
called his wife she called him her
husband they all gave
very harrowing accounts on the witness
stand about what their lives were like
with larry ray there had been testimony
by the mother about not hearing from her
children about santos being desperate
for money
that prosecutors allege he was forced to
pay to
larry ray and so that was a
note to end
very powerful testimony on the trial
karen the prosecution ends on a jail on
jailhouse calls
do you think this is an iron-clad case
or can you see places where reasonable
doubt can crack the prosecution's case
it's appears to be an ironclad case we
have these
witnesses testifying to this horrendous
experience and we have this older person
that basically takes advantage of these
uh young people and used his daughter
basically to to get the trust of these
other individuals that were at the
school and it's just
unheard of to have a parent living on
campus in the dormitory so that that
that is really outrageous so i think
that there has been enough evidence
presented beyond a reasonable doubt to
convict him of of these these federal
offenses yeah i won't lie as a defense
attorney i'm always looking at these
cases we cover and say hey here's an
argument here here's an argument here i
don't see one here but terry from what
we've heard of the defense's cross
examinations who do you think they'll
have testify seems they've already want
the former lawyer glenn ripa to testify
listen i agree with both of you this
looks like an iron clad case as far as
the prosecution is concerned but the
defense has made a couple of points here
remember they had claudia drury on the
stand for days and they did get her to
admit that she embellished and she
fabricated certain details so i think
they're making some small points but
very small as far as calling ray's prior
counsel to the stand they're going to
have to do that the defense has already
signaled in a memo that they're going to
try to use advice of council defense and
that when
ray accepted compensation from drury
that that was because
he was authorized to do that because it
was for jury's sex work and she poisoned
him none of it brian makes any sense if
you ask me i can't imagine an attorney
advising someone that this was
acceptable but they're going to have to
call him to the stand they're going to
have to ask him all of those questions
and we'll find out and get to the bottom
of it absolutely let's figure out how
this legal advice went well thank you
both and thank you for joining us here
at law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you